i
declare
bankruptcy
hey i just wanted you to know that you
can't just say the word bankruptcy and
expect anything to happen i didn't say
it i declared it still that's
it's not anything
this is a lot of credit card debt yeah
tell me about it
you know jan has my credit cards and
she's
using them as if i'm made of money she
thinks i'm a human atm machine
okay 125 amazon
oh best of the muppet show on dvd
classic
twelve hundred dollars what's a core
blaster extreme that is by far
the best way to strengthen your core
this machine
you sit on a stabilizer ball you put
your feet into the power stirrups you
reach up and you grab onto the super rod
and you twist and you twist and you
twist it strengthens your entire core
your back core
your arm core
your
the marine core actually uses it i think
that's how they got core
so so who's leading this thing anyway
so who's leading this thing anyway
say i can't wait to meet him
[Applause]
i can't wait to meet him
him
you say
don't think a woman can be a leader
hey you poor simple boy
expected a man did you strong powerful
huge whopping penis wow sorry to
disappoint but my huge whopping penis is
right here
and i'm not afraid to use it
so stop looking at my breasts
and start looking at my penis
i'm nellie bertson
president of special projects in the
next few weeks we're going to throw
everything you know about business out
of the window
and do it our own way are your minds
blown
so
how did this special project come about
anyway well
i interviewed to be the manager
of
your branch
after you decided i wasn't a good fit it
was
it was i went on a shopping spree
very destructive i bought 13 pianos
what's going on here poppy mommy's here
can we keep him my neighbor's dog had a
literally looking for people to adopt i
love him
i wish he had tiny puppy shoes
i would totally shine his little shoes
for free oh i do say the cutest stuff
look i love a good dog as much as the
next guy but this building doesn't allow
animals andy take him outside
and shoot him no just
keep him outside oh come on ron
i'm just a little puppy
i ain't done nothing wrong i'm just a
puppy
i like your mustache
i wish i could have one but i can't
cause i'm just a little bubbly
hmm
okay take him out and shoot him i guess
we can make a switch to bermuda grass
it's only 80 cents more per square foot
what
give me give me give me
you want me to put bermuda grass in a
continental climate that's a six on the
beaufort scale in a park with zero
drainage i want kentucky bluegrass i
want a 10 discount and i want you to
apologize to my best friend donna
yeah hi is there
and i'm just guessing here's some kind
of medication that you maybe need a lot
of and have taken none of or maybe too
much of today oh i have i have a medical
condition all right it's called caring
too much
and it's incurable
also i have eczema
i'm tired of politics
let's get that punk blood so
this is amazing of course we have no
idea where he is but i love where your
head's at he has no family maybe there
was a girlfriend or someone he worked
with at the coffee shop the coffee shop
why would someone who knows they have 21
million dollars coming take a minimum
wage job because he needed access to
that building because that's where the
money's hidden all right we gotta get
there quick maybe we should take the
chopper
here's that chopper deathblade
sidewinder it's go time roger that wet
blanket no from now on call me
velvet
thunder
okay
amy santiago
will you marry me what okay really could
you stay in the cab i'm sorry i'll be
right there i promise or maybe i won't
what's your answer teddy i don't want to
be with you but you want to be with him
you guys have nothing in common oh yeah
tell that to william atherton the man we
both considered to be the second best
die-hard villain oh she meant it and
also yes we are different people but i
love that about us i love that jake's a
little messy and that he cares so much
about his dumb sneakers and he doesn't
get stressed out about calendars or
flossing my teeth no the non-flossing is
crazy copy that and i love you i'm just
so confused your fight was like
something out of a movie
teddy i have to tell you the truth no
amy is dying she has one month to live
marrying her would be a waste of time
jake and i were only pretending to fight
so that we could destroy your phone
while we were on the stakeout and you
were in the bathroom we said you were
the most boring man in america and your
phone recorded it i'm sorry we didn't
want you to get mad at us and fail the
precinct wow
you guys are the worst well you just
proposed in front of your girlfriend so
potato potato amy i loved you
all right i'm ready to go rachel should
we hit up the tenement museum no
secrets stolen
from deep inside you know this song
already of course i do everyone knows
the song it's amazing the drum beats out
of time if you're lost you can look and
you will find me
time after time
if you fall i will catch you oh i'll be
waiting
time after time
time after time
time after time
good stuff it's never happened
no no wait what am i doing
this isn't the way i want this to happen
again
leslie it's not that big a deal
i think you should go homework
all right
okay
i'm sorry that's uh
i'm gonna get out of here i'm sorry it's
okay
no oh my god oh oh
oh my god oh my god mark are you all
right
wow
are you okay
oh my god if someone broke into your
apartment and you weren't cops
wouldn't you be scared
yes
depends
how many guns do i still have hidden no
do i stole my knife
nunchucks
axe it was a hypothetical question i
know but i want to play it out
do i solve my throwing stars
this is taking a strange turn
fine
i'd be scared
we're on it
kind of woman doesn't have an axe
you